Okay, so the correct answer is for the title,
we're going to use a string.
For the art, we're also going to use a string,
and for the created, we're also going--we're going to use a date time.
Now, actually I lied to you,
we're not going to use a string, we're going to use something called text,
but there is no way for me to ask a quiz without giving away the answer.
I learned while writing this that there is
another type called text,
and the difference between a string and a text
is that a string must be under 500 characters
and can be indexed.
Text can be greater than 500 characters,
which is really handy for ASCII art.
ASCII art that is under 500 characters is not very fun at all.
I actually learned this while building this lesson,
and text cannot be indexed,
which means of course that we can't sort based on a text property.
This is fine, you know in our case, we're going to
sort probably on the created property
so we can show things in order.
We won't be able to sort things by the artwork,
which is fine, because what would that even mean?
So if we were to use the string data type,
which we're going to use on our titles, yeah it is indexed so you can do queries,
you can say get me the artwork to title = X.
You can't--we can't do a query get me the art where text = X
because it's not indexed.
Let's go ahead and define our data type.